parker  parker  what's wrong  it's back he's here  what  he'll  [Music]  wow peter wow  i thought we were close  fury always had to die but not you  stop hiding back  i tried to help you walk away  now you're making me do this  you told me you were just a kid  you told me  you wanted to run after that girl  peter what's going on i know this isn't  real do you though  okay  [Applause]  i don't think you know what's real peter  you need to great job  [Music]  i mean look at yourself  [Music]  you are just a scared little kid in a  sweat suit  i created mysterio to give the world  someone to believe in  i control the truth mysterio is the  truth  [Music]  [Music]  if you were good enough  maybe tony would still be alive  deep down  you know i'm right  you made your choice  and all you had to do was step aside  and now  you  have to  [Music]  you